thank you
[Applause]
what's up guys we're pongfinity as some
of you have seen we have launched our
own table tennis racket it's a pumpkin
at the Sensei which is a five-star
complete racket today we'll be comparing
it to the cheapest one star racket we
could find let's see what the difference
is let's put the spin to the test do
some ghosts start off with the one
dollar rackets
[Music]
[Applause]
you can get at least sunscreen with that
one let's try the pumpkin is the sensor
foreign
[Applause]
comes back much faster when hit with the
five-star racket so there's a lot more
spin in the ball okay I'll try to
receive the spinniest possible serve
that Otto can do and I'll start with the
fun Infinity racket ready I'm ready
[Applause]
and I actually aimed like there
[Music]
whoa
It's Impossible now let's try the one
star racket
foreign
[Applause]
okay okay
it almost like eliminates the spin so
that's good with this I want to start
rocket wins this challenge
it's actually quite good control for it
I mean you can't get that much spin but
it's got feeling
wrong
you can get a better curve on the five
star one but you can do it with both
let's try out the world's fastest serve
with the one star racket
[Applause]
surprisingly good
that would have been fast hard to get
the spin on it
that was okay
well you can do it with this one but I
think we can get it faster with a five
star racket let's try it
[Applause]
oh yeah
a lot better we can do faster
[Applause]
yeah it was a lot better with this one
because you need the grip to get the
speed now let's see how it Compares in
gameplay
[Applause]
records
[Music]
[Music]
yes it's impossible to hit like quality
top spins with this all right let's take
a Target shot battle first one to knock
down the cops wins
oh
oh yeah yeah this is much better
[Applause]
oh come back that's my favorite one
yes
well oh two one
well
20 better maybe the target shot isn't
the best measure for control but that
was fun anyway at least a fun experience
that's why I see flux with the one Star
Records
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
feels so much easier with this one
yeah and anything else Let's test some
chops
thank you
[Applause]
surprisingly good chops
[Applause]
[Music]
it was a lot harder hitting from Emma's
five-star chops than the one star chops
because they were a lot lower and a lot
spinnier yeah I play some rallies
against Mexico with the one star racket
see how it goes
[Applause]
I have to leave the block last night in
the air
[Applause]
oh nice one yeah the biggest difference
is the block
[Music]
oh
my God
the top space
nice so all in all there was a clear
defect between the two rackets
especially in the gameplay if you're a
beginner or intermediate to pumpkin at
the Sensei is the perfect choice for you
so go and get yours from pongfinity dot
store until next time